joining us now here on the Rich Eisen
show I love chatting with this man I
love chatting baseball with this guy and
I hope I do get to chat actual baseball
games and strategy and what's going on
in a twenty20 playing season with him he
is from Sports Illustrated in Fox Sports
and MLB Network the ultimate - it Tom
Verducci back here on the show how are
you Tom I am well Rick how are you I am
doing well where do things stand right
now with Major League Baseball best you
can tell for this season there's a soft
deadline coming up you know in order to
have an 82-game season that starts
around 4th of July weekend they need to
get players in camp by about June 13th
so I you know I figure about June 9th or
10th that's when they have to come to an
agreement to make that possible it's not
a really hard deadline rich you could
always have say a 60 game season but an
82 game one but this is what we have in
front of us right now and right now both
sides are really dug in and if you just
go by the temperature of negotiations
right now you would say that an
agreement is not likely but if you step
back from it and you think about what is
the cost of no agreement and no baseball
in 2020 I think that makes you
optimistic or at least me that these two
sides will come to the realization that
they need one another if the battle of
wills don't be no baseball because he
dug in but if the battle of intellect
and compromise and negotiation and
understanding of how important not just
this year is but the next couple of
years then yes there will be one what
best you can tell was the owners offer
if you will and because you know the
concept is again if I'm not wrong before
before you get to it that the owners
think what well the players think what
was negotiated in March is what is
applicable now and owners say that
there's now been a change in reality
from March and we got to talk about
something else here and players think
that that what is being offered is a
second pay cut that also could mimic a
salary cap is that an actual is it an
accurate assessment of what's going on
- yeah that's a good job I mean that
agreement in March that was put in place
the players are essentially saying no
backsies yes we negotiate an agreement
and we're going to get paid based on how
many games are played on a pro-rated
basis of our annual 20/20 salaries the
owners are saying wait a second we
actually have a provision in that
agreement that says we will continue to
discuss the economics if we have to play
an empty ballpark obviously now it looks
like that could be probably an entire
season with no fans so the economic
realities according to the owners have
changed since March and the player to
say no it hasn't you know we have our
agreement that's that so that's kind of
a sticking point here the players and
you saw the quote from Max Scherzer
Wednesday night saying we're not taking
a second pay cut but obviously the
owners are saying things are a lot
different now you mentioned a salary cap
that was not a formal proposal to the
player that was floated the idea that
hey revenues are so far dad well we'll
gladly share with the players 50% of our
revenues well
listen 21 to the 30 teams weren't around
in 1994 when we lost the World Series
because the owner has tried to get a
salary cap they should still know
there's no way that's wise that's a
complete non-starter with the Union that
was a waste of time it probably ticked
off some people unnecessarily so now
their idea is we will use a sliding pay
scale in terms of the cuts that we're
going to ask players and take now I know
the players look at that as hey you're
trying to drive a wedge between the high
revenue that high income guys we're
going to take the largest percentage cut
against the so-called you know most
players two-thirds of players make a
million dollars or less the
rank-and-file so I don't think that was
the purpose here was it divided the
players I think what MLB is doing is
what they're doing on a club basis what
many businesses are doing and they're
asking the highest salaried employees to
take a larger percentage cut during a
pandemic it wasn't like they came up
with this idea themselves it's happening
across Wall Street it's happening across
Main Street but the players did not take
kindly to that so the player is now the
balls in their court
they got this proposal about a sliding
pay scale they've made the
their feelings known that they hate it
they don't like it so they have to come
back with something and their idea is to
come back with saying hey how about we
play more games and the owners position
on this I believe is wait a second these
games still won't have fans in the stand
so 100 games time zero ballpark revenue
is exactly the same sum as 82 games
times zero and the other thing is really
key here rich is that they want to play
the players want to play more games and
push the world series to say November I
think that's a non-starter for the
owners because everybody in not just
baseball but in general people are
worried about a second wave of the virus
right well yes the flu season they want
to get the world series done by the end
of October so pushing it to November is
really risky in the owners opinion
because believe it or not make it almost
60 percent of their national TV revenue
just in the post season this year that's
essentially a billion dollar pot that's
out there if the post season has played
the completion so they don't want to
risk that so I think the idea of playing
more games extending the season is not a
that's not going to solve this I don't
think well and then there's you know
when when they come up with a proposal
that says the higher paid guys will take
the cuts and the lower paid guys won't
how do they not think that that won't be
viewed by the Union is something that
puts the pressure on the highest paid
guys to do something to make sure the
lower paid guys don't look at them
adversely how how could that possibly be
forwarded without the knowledge of how
it would be taken and received you know
my I get it you know I totally get it
the response was almost predictable but
again this is what teams are doing on
club basis it's the same week the
Nationals did that the Dodgers did that
asking employees to take pay cuts based
on a sliding pay scale so my question
for you is is happening is the players
now have found a unified voice listen we
know that they didn't really do well in
the last CBA right at least economically
they did roll with some quality of life
issues in terms of off days in the
scheduling things like that economically
they didn't do well I thought during the
whole--you Sinestro sign ceiling scandal
and that seems like ages ago doesn't
that that kind of split third the Union
right there was a players who were
calling out other player that doesn't
happen too often but now I think they
have found a common voice and it's
essentially on being asked to take what
they see as a second pay cut man ok Tom
Verducci Sports Illustrated Fox Sports
and MLB Network Sports Illustrated I
think I said that too I can't keep up
with you so um so when it comes down to
it what's with the Scott Boras stuff now
what Trevor Bauer threw out there what
was yves obviously referring to i guess
the email that The Associated Press
obtained basically Boras saying the
owners aren't talking about losing money
in a playing season they're talking
about not having the money to pay off
the debt that Major League Baseball
allowed them to use to jack up the price
of their team or the valuation of their
team and your salaries would be viewed
as a bailout this is what the math that
he said what about that yeah well first
of all Scott has and should have
tremendous influence in this game based
on his track record how long he's been
in the game the clientele that he has I
mean they do define what a billion
dollars worth of contracts this past
offseason he clearly has the ear of Tony
Clark
he has three players who are on the
union's executive for it no other agent
has more than one so he does have an
outside influence as far as an agent in
the Union matters go so I don't see that
necessarily as a negative thing and
again I think he's been the one sort of
rallying players you know he came out
with his email I didn't see much from
Tony Clark but you heard Scott Boras
loud and clear now as he said he's
saying the owners problem is listen
these people took out loans to renovate
their stadiums to build ballpark
villages and even the purchased teams
and that's their mistake well that's not
entirely true
what
steak if there is a mistake is what
every business is its fighting now it's
called a global pandemic
you know everybody if you ran a
restaurant and you took out a loan to
renovate your restaurant are you gonna
blame the pandemic because your business
is down you know this is really
unprecedented times you know emotionally
and especially economically and I think
what he needs to do Scott and all the
Union in general is where is the common
ground basically I think players and
owners need to invest in one another for
the good of the sport going forward not
to say who's right or who's wrong in May
of 2020 but what does this sport look
like rich if there's no baseball this
year if you as a fan or watching say the
NFL the NBA the NHL tennis golf you name
it baseball from Japan Korea soccer
across the world and there's no baseball
because baseball players and owners
could not agree on economics not safety
protocol economics splitting up the
money during a pandemic what do you
think that does for the game going
forward what is it for free agency this
offseason what does it do for next year
in terms of negotiating towards a new
CBA which expires at the end of next
year what does it do for clubs who are
trying to sell sponsorship and
advertising after essentially
seventeenth and nineteen months of
baseball going dark two people being
added out of the habit of following
baseball I mean that is a bleak
landscape if you're talking about
baseball being the only sport that is
not out there or at least trying to find
a way to put their sport out in front of
the public and again I'm going to use my
restaurant analogy again your favorite
restaurant closes for a year-long
renovation guess what you get into the
habit of fighting another restaurant
right I mean that's a scary thing for
restaurants to be down for that long and
if baseball does not give people the
option of following the game for a year
and a half I'm afraid a lot of people
will have moved on see I'll ask you the
same question I asked our colleague at
ESPN Jeff Passan when he was on
yesterday it sure feels like this is a
CBA negotiation but that because one is
coming up next year that there's a lot
of territory being staked out for the
mother lode conversation next year that
appears to now be front-loaded now at
the worst possible time would you agree
with that yeah I do
rich Anna and I think I don't know if
this is possible I mean I hate to even
propose ideas that would quote unquote
help solve a very complex
yes labor dispute yes but you know go
back to 1981 when he has that two-month
player strike and part of the settlement
was that they agreed to extend the CBA
by a year essentially for the same
reason you just brought up because
things are so toxic right now it's going
to be hard to get to a new huge overall
agreement so just kind of put it off for
another year so I agree that you can't
think about these negotiations without
thinking about the next CBA being right
around the corner so here's a little
solve I've got to start Tom because you
know again there may be an iron-rich and
eyes and there's an eye on for do Qi but
we're team players we're trying to
figure this thing out
doesn't baseball have already agreed
with the players and vice versa on a
schedule where it would be or at least
what it would look like that they could
Ford so we could all discuss that while
they're doing this under that cover in
the same way I'm assuming the NHL is
doing with its players right now
potentially that they've they've come up
with here's what it will look like when
we return wherever that may be whenever
that may be but we're talking about that
and saying hey hockey's trying they
might be having similar conversations
with their their players now about
safety protocols and things like that
doesn't base what so I guess two prong
doesn't baseball have something like
that to come out and say hey while we're
figuring this out here baseball fans is
what it would look like how cool will
this be when the Yankees take on the Red
Sox 19 million times because they're in
close proximity with each other you know
I mean like isn't there something like
that but that's that's in a top drawer
for for them to bust out yeah it's a
good idea I think the problem is that
schedule is probably not something that
they feel complete
when to at this point I mean they do
have the framework of a schedule 82
games when I understand
they'll play to home at home series
against teams and their division and one
home and home series against the like
division of the other league in
interleague game so that really reduces
travel which i think is a great idea I
love the idea that it really reinforces
the value of winning your division and a
short season 82 games you're playing
most of your games within your division
so if you finish first place that's
awesome you've earned it and the
postseason will be different you'll get
seven teams in each league instead of
five the first round you'll have
wildcard series three games all in one
ballpark best out of three and instead
of one game knockout so those things are
in place I just don't think they've
locked down the schedule enough to say
here it is public you know here's what
you can look forward to but I do think
it's a good idea Ridgid anything they
can give fans about hope of a baseball
season and what it looks like there has
to be a good thing rather than you know
these updates on negotiations which on a
daily basis are not good I mean I've
heard anything positive because of these
talks on a daily basis I mean my spirits
perked up even hearing you describe that
Tom I'll be honest with you here
I'm like okay so that sounds good so
that would be the American League in the
National League East faced one another
and likewise Central and West right and
then and and then we'll just have to
deal with the Toronto of it all in the
in the American League and nationally
east about going from Canada to America
which I imagine is going to be something
of an issue to deal with but I mean
that's a bridge right now that you know
there is obviously no crossing the
border so my solution would be that they
train at their spring training site and
Dunedin Florida and the Blue Jays play
their home games at Tropicana Field I
mean you can do that you can share the
ballpark will be playing the Rays a lot
anyway so this there might be one or two
places where the ballparks would have to
be you know played in a neutral or
shared situation but I think the idea of
playing essentially reinforcing your
regional rivalries is a really cool idea
maybe that's there's something in that
going forward as well so I guess last
one for you is percentage-wise it for me
you know cuz again right now it seems
pretty dark there's not much dawn you
did give a soft deadlines and that
usually does spur action and I guess
just to reiterate you think both sides
are aware of the fallout that would
happen if they throw their arms up over
economic problems not public and health
problems right so yeah that's why I'm
optimistic and that's why I would say
you know if you want a percentage say
2/3 66 percent I you know I just imagine
you know two kids standing on a cliff
and saying man what would it feel like
if we jumped off this cliff you know it
feels like if your players and owners if
you jump off this cliff and what the
Ripper repercussions are so that to me
is the strongest motivator to get a deal
done and again 82-game sounds right
you know it's virtually the half of a
season but I know you could still have a
sixty game season and again the whole
key you need a viable postseason to have
that billion dollar payout of the
national TV money that's why that I
think there has to be some sort of
bonuses attached the player pay because
if there is a second way but coronavirus
and that wipes out the postseason that
ways had a billion dollars of TV money
and you know that's really significant
when it comes to the ability to pay the
players but yeah I think listen you
remember that you probably do the 81
season and the split season they came
back and you know you could get a
playoff spot in the second half of the
season and that was only what
40-something games or something like
that forty to fifty games is it ideal no
but I still think you could have a 45 to
50 game season and go into a postseason
but I think 82 is right now this is a
deadline that's in front of us
again I'm optimistic that baseball finds
a way to get the sport on the field me
too
Tom thanks for the time I trust
everybody in your world is happy and
healthy I I hope
yeah hopefully I get to see at a
ballpark in July or somewhere after that
well I guess again I'm for sure press
access would be restricted right I mean
like that's that at least that has that
even been agreed to protocols I mean
like his base written they'd be happy to
have anybody who come wants to come out
and cover the game listener you have
empty ballpark so the plenty of seats is
helpful in terms of social distancing
for media members I think the what
shades you would see is one broadcast
crew doing the game in other words you
know a road team wouldn't be sending
their camera operators and even
announcers out there just to keep those
numbers down otherwise yeah anybody
wants to come out to the game I'm sure
they're welcome to come out and cover it
you're not going to get Clubhouse access
right but you can get a good seat in the
fan he goes good seats are available
thanks to the call Tom really appreciate
it you be well
we'll chat soon hopefully got a return
of this four that's Tom Verducci hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here